good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday hope
everyone's oh happy election day it is
the 8th of November therefore it is
election day hope everyone's having a
great election day it's a great day to
be an American it is I hope everyone is
taking the time to vote whether before
work after work during work you are
entitled to time to vote during your job
today so make sure that you do your
civic duty
knew you were gonna say that
because one thing about me it's like I
am a four-year-old you know for sure and
here's the thing like I don't want to
get political so early this morning but
I feel like I need to take a stand and
say that okay I'm voting for Bryce for
governor
um and I know you're voting for strikes
I am and you know that's the thing about
the toast it's like we don't let
politics come between us you know
everyone is welcome here at this show
whether you voted for Bryce or Strife
it's so true so
hot take though hot take I know I know
people aren't gonna like that but I said
what I said and I felt like I had to you
know I had to it was your civic duty it
was my duty
so we're coming off of a great episode
yesterday except for the astigmatism
should we talk about the astigmatism
yeah so weird yesterday I mean I had to
rearrange my studio because we went from
two to one and I can't see I see my
monitor from where I'm sitting but I was
too far away to realize that it was out
of focus so it was out of focus the
whole time which is so sad because I
looked so stunning I gave my heart and
soul to the episode I was wearing
Claudia's necklace that she got me and
none of it was seen really so
I'm sorry no you know what's tough about
doing what we do in such an authentic
honest real on unfiltered unedited raw
way is like we do this show and like we
really we we don't re-record stuff like
we don't edit stuff so we sit here and
we talk for an hour and if you know
every now and then we'll realize like oh
we didn't press record on this Mike and
it's like that moment is gone and we
can't recreate it you know at least I
had something and we were able to do a
video but I'm sure it was kind of
painful to watch except if you have an
astigmatism and then like you took out
your contacts maybe it was actually on
balance for you because and that's where
we wasn't that's what we do here at the
toast we try to make the show accessible
for everyone even those with astigmatism
it's true but this morning Zach double
check my camera I think I'm in Focus I
tinkered around a little bit and I would
just feel so upset if not everyone could
see my gorgeous outfit today which is a
little redheads merch always wrapping
the red heads I want to be honest
because I feel like honesty is a core
value of our show
um and I really like I was not really
mad
um that your video was off the cocked
because that meant like more eyes were
probably just like staring at me the
whole time and I happened to have looked
particularly stunning yesterday so if
your camera isn't fixed again today like
I think I'll be okay well you know I do
it for you everything I do I do with you
in mind I know and it's like I think on
some subconscious level you were really
just like letting me have a moment
yesterday letting you shine there was a
lot of talk about me my birthday how's
Jackie how's 30 but like what about
Claudia nobody ever asks yesterday how's
Claudia
thank you really truly thank you
so how is Claudia
been great you know I'm feeling I'm
feeling excited you know there's
something about I've weirdly been like
looking forward to election day I feel
like the last couple of election days
like I've had a lot of anxiety but I
don't know there's something exciting
about just like you know like everyone
watching the same thing tonight do you
know what I mean I know and I don't
really have plans for this but an
election night chili
is a really great thing to do let me
explain I've done it before so all day
you're prepping the chili as you know
the votes are coming in the chili is
stewing and by the time news is coming
in like you sit down with your chili and
you enjoy
no that's a really kind of beautiful and
poetic way of looking at a great day in
our nation Club elections are like chili
you put a lot of stuff in and you get
your results
hmm yeah I like that I think that was
Thoreau who said that I actually think
it was Walt Whitman they are the same
person to me so
okay I'm so glad you brought that up
Ralph Waldo Emerson
Walt Whitman
Justin Thoreau
all the same oh and Justin Trudeau like
all the same people to me no
no what is thoreau's first name and
actually I do think that all of these
boys are from like the same period
I feel like I learned about them all on
the same day in English class and that's
why like they're all the same in my mind
Ralph Waldo Emerson Walt Whitman Thoreau
Henry David Thoreau see he's just like a
one name Wonder to me
100 of The Branding it's like a Madonna
and they were all at Walden the Lakes
where all the poets went to die I
actually think this is who Taylor was
talking about I'm not even lying
no these are the Walden boys yet people
also search for Ralph Waldo Emerson
walth Whitman uh Cynthia Dunbar
Nathaniel Hawthorne if you're a redhead
that name no I don't know Cynthia
Cynthia like not to belittle her but
she's probably someone's wife
Jackie she is well it is she is the
mother of Henry David Thoreau so okay it
is that time of year where like you know
I start to become like a male chauvinist
because it's holiday season the Hallmark
movies coming out and as I always say I
am a card-carrying feminist most of the
time but when those holiday movies come
out you know women
the kitchen
men the office men The Lumberjack tree
we need wood for this fire and the women
this fire isn't going to burn itself no
this tree isn't gonna chop itself no no
and you know what these cookies aren't
going to bake themselves either so I'll
just see myself to the kitchen yeah
definitely I actually think I'm gonna do
some baking today some election day
baking because I've got some bananas
that are ripe for muffins well
we also have just like a fabulous show
today because like weirdly there's a lot
of news today and the beginning of the
week your relevant girly watch my mind
and me and the culpos
great we have a story about the culpos
that will lead into our TV recap
oh okay so why don't you tell me about
your mind and you
I'll tell you about it one I agree with
everything that was said yesterday
um but I had some additional thoughts
first of all this came to me at the end
when the the documentary ends with her
young self saying I am Selena and it
made me realize that the title of the
documentary is not good it's not my mind
and me I feel like we didn't get a look
inside her mind we gotta look inside her
life the ways that she referred to her
mind and what she thinks and feels like
we're kind of vague I don't feel like we
got a really good look at the mind of
Selena but I feel like we got a good
look at the life of Selena so I would
say they should have called it I am
Selena
alternate title gotta keep an eye out
for something that was that was going to
be my next suggestion of course right if
they wanted to be culturally relevant
the other thing there were so many
things but the other thing is that this
period that they're showing up is
obviously a really hard time for Selena
she's coming back into the spotlight
she's struggling with trying to maintain
her sanity and doing the job that she
needs to do that affords her all of the
Privileges to do the things that she
wants to do but I'm so curious one how
covid changed her like was Covenant
staying home good for her because I feel
like for a lot of celebrities like Ari I
feel like it was the best thing that
could have happened like you have to
stay home no one's coming to see your
shows you need to take a break and I
wonder how that was for her to a point I
think like everyone else you know we had
our break and then it became dark being
so isolated especially if you're someone
who struggles with mental health issues
like it was a net negative for most
people but I just was curious and they
showed us some coveted stuff so I was
just curious if like if if she was able
to like reconnect with herself like love
her house again love her life and just
you know maybe cook and and how was that
for her that's interesting then after
kovid her business really changed she
did rare Beauty only murders in the
building and there's one oh uh Selena
and Chef and so these are very different
than her being like an album artist tour
tour bus another bus tour and no sleep
how has this stage of her career
affected her mental health is this so
much better for her working on rare
Beauty where she doesn't need to be
public facing as much you know the money
comes in without her having to do all of
these radio interviews and I'm just
curious like where she's at now I feel
like that's a really good point I feel
like in in a way the documentary is
almost a little dated yeah and it ends
so abruptly and her whole career has
changed now and I also wonder like what
is her passion when she was working at
seven years old and she was doing Barney
it sounded like she was loving acting
and somewhere along the way like that
went South I wonder if it was you know
the Disney environment at Disney and
then my next question is what happened
at Disney that she feels like she can't
even dress like it a little witchy
because people think of her as a witch
I'm like I forgot Alex Russo is a wizard
of differently she's just like a Disney
kid but that's how deep it runs for her
so I'm like what I'm thinking what
happened there but what I know her
passion is the philanthropy and I know
that she feels her best when she's
helping other people and is able to not
feel like she's taking and she's giving
but as far as like the craft what is her
passion does she love does she love
writing music does she love acting does
she love doing only murders in the
building like does she feel like she
likes writing music but doesn't like
performing it should she be a songwriter
I just felt like what about this trade
which at one point you loved
do you still feel like is a huge part of
you and you don't want to give up or do
you hate it that's a really good
question honestly I feel like she
definitely loves acting yeah because she
chose to do only murders in the building
she's not doing music right now so tell
us that and and so that we can be happy
that and you know she is kind of a
serious actor she's done Woody Allen a
lot of the serious people that she's
worked with really love her and even for
Steve Martin and Martin Martin Short to
have chosen her is such an honor and she
is such she's so deserving and does she
love that
um yeah that's actually so true I feel
like
at this rate she'll be a more respected
actress than musician because honestly
she hasn't there's a song My Mind in me
and she released rare but like it's she
doesn't have a huge discography because
she really doesn't do that much music so
is that what she wants to be doing are
things going better now because she's
not doing music LMK
no that's a really good question did you
and then also it's like she doesn't like
doing the radio interviews and I totally
understood like some of those questions
were so dumb but then on the flip side
it's like you sit down and they're
asking you the deepest questions and
it's like I don't [ __ ] know you I'm
not gonna give you like my heart and
soul for a couple clicks
why can't we just have a normal
conversation
um I wanted to clarify one thing because
a lot of people were like having
conversations after our episode
yesterday about the Raquel of it all so
Raquel is listed as a producer on the
documentary therefore meaning she
probably like made money off of it and I
don't know if she's like a salaried by
Selena but she definitely has you know
some sort of
Financial benefit from being her friend
so that's important to note but I was
curious what your thoughts are or were
on the Raquel of it all I thought Raquel
was a great friend I can see how you
know they obviously conf there's
conflict between them but they spend 24
7 together and that's another thing
that's so unnatural it's like Selena's
laying in her bed like clearly depressed
and there's all these other people
around the room with her the cameras are
there because we're watching it and it's
like leave her alone like having the
like I understand she wants to do this
documentary because she feels like it's
her way to help people see that they're
not alone but like
that would cost too much for her like
she when she's in bed just like can't
turn her brain off like it's not helpful
to have cameras in her face and who
knows there's probably a boom mic
there's a million things there's a
million people and like
uh don't do this like in service for us
when you need help too and I feel like a
lot of the message of her documentaries
like I really want to help people
and I think but I think in a lot of ways
the documentary will help people see
that even the people that we love so
much are struggling people like she's
just like us but and sadly and maybe she
has them now but this ended in 2020 and
she didn't then but in the documentary
like there's really no tools for how to
overcome a dark period And I I wish that
there was more
not even optimism at the end of it
because I understand that like hard
times come and it's hard and that's not
how it always is but like
we sh like
it's not enough just to say like I
experienced this too or like you know we
should talk about mental health like we
can't just be talking about mental
health we also need to be helping people
and like giving them tools giving them
resources showing them you know I was
here once but look where I am now like
it gets better I feel like we were
talking about this two weeks ago so many
people are just like living in their
sadness and feeling like it can't get
better and I'm watching Selena live her
life and she's so unhappy and I'm like
life is not supposed to be like that and
I understand that for for more some
people are unhappier more times and some
people are happier not everyone's the
same but on the whole like
we should be able to find pockets of
life that we enjoy and I think that a
lot of the messaging that's out there
for kids like needs to be in re
affirming that over and over again like
life is wonderful and yes and heart and
like you know your mind can play tricks
on you and sometimes it's not just
situational and it's not just a bad
period and you need help and you need
people to talk to and perhaps even
medication sometimes but like it really
it should get better and I felt like the
documentary ended and I felt so like
upset this girl is just yeah you know
she has seemingly quote unquote like
everything perfect life yeah a person
could desire in order to live a happy
life and and she's so unhappy and it
just made me really sad and it made me
sad for the people who might watch it
and and not see a way out of it and not
have like there was no like takeaway no
and at the end it's like if you're
feeling this way like all 988 but it's
you know what is 98 going to tell you to
do let's put that in there too and and
if Selena is doing better now which I
feel like she is because she's working
and I feel like she is too tell us how
to get there she got there tell or at
least tell us how you got there yeah of
course because it's not the same for
everyone but no I agree like there was
this overall sadness that I feel like I
was left with at the end of the
documentary and and kind of unresolved
and I think you pointing out the fact
that like it doesn't include the last
two years which I feel like from afar
have been very good for her
um it felt unfinished yeah so I thought
Raquel was a great friend and I was
looking at her Instagram and she wrote a
book with Tanya radd did you see that
yes she's also very close friends with
Haley Bieber it oh interesting but it
made me so glad because I was thinking
like Tanya rat is someone to me who like
embodies Sunshine positivity and
positivity I'm like okay so if Ty is
friends with Raquel that means Raquel
you know has some of that positive
energy which we even saw in the thing
when they're talking in Africa she's
like what can we implementing your life
you're not supposed to let's do this
quarterly yeah she's like you're not
supposed to not want to go home you're
not supposed to not want to look at your
phone link what can we do and changing
your life that will make you happier to
live it and I feel like she that's
exactly what someone should be doing to
help lift Selena up so it made me happy
to see that she has that positivity that
Tanya radd has because I feel like
that's a great influence for Selena
yeah no that's a really good point
um I think those are very one more point
about laying in the bed with the friends
which is unnatural like for a 30 year
old woman to be having sleepovers every
single night with her friends the thing
about having friends who work for you or
or are going to be with you 24 7 is that
that means that they can't hold another
job because they are with you 24 7. so
they can't you know make their own money
so they are essentially you know and
then inevitably living off of you and
that that makes it unhealthy but it's
hard she needs friends around her and so
she can't have friends who have jobs and
aren't going to be there all the time
but it also creates this Dynamic where
it's like people should be able to be
alone and then at the end of the day
we'll meet up with our friends we'll
have a good time and then I I go back to
being like myself and in my life so I
feel like so many celebrities like live
with their friends sleep with their
friends and
you create this dependency that's really
hard like a toxic Dynamic yeah yeah no
that's a good point a lot of celebrities
like have these groups of friends these
posses that live with them depend on
them spend 24 7 together and it creates
this very bizarre dynamic because it's
not like a
I thought a natural thing to be you know
30 40 years old and have a million
people living in your house who are your
friends yeah and it's like Selena will
wake up and she's you know not in a good
mood or she's feeling depressed or
anxious and then there's all these
people in her bed who are like want to
do this want to do that it's like just
let Selena like lay and and figure out
what she wants to do next without you
want to eat you want to watch a movie
like it's so true
but also yeah no totally but also Selena
will know that they're down the hall if
she needs them yeah that's true but
being alone and that's I feel like what
Matthew Perry was saying not that it's
the same but he's like
you'll know I'm in trouble if I really
want to be alone and of course that has
to do with addiction
um but I think the same can be said
about mental health like if people like
being alone is not always the best thing
no no but
if you're on you need to be able to be
alone yes of course like and it's yeah
and she would I feel like she wasn't
alone till covid really but even then
like we see her she's like cleaning her
house she's doing like a workout from
home and she's productive yeah because
there's no one in bed doing everything
for her for her yeah that was a major
takeaway for me is like that you know
her whole life is planned and she's very
much coddled by the people in her life
and I think at first that was probably
for her benefit but now I think it's you
know as she heals it's to her detriment
yes definitely which is why again I'm
curious about covet and then to me the
most curious interesting part that was
not explored was what happened with we
charity
that I'm gonna need an episode of
American Greed I like what that was plot
twist no that was so weird
I meant to Google it after like what do
you mean for like what the [ __ ] no it
was so random and like she had these Big
Dreams and and they were crushed because
there was like fraud uh like what
no it was very bizarre so would have
loved to learn more about that right so
overall I feel like the documentary was
meant for us you know to like take away
certain things and I took away a lot but
I don't think it was what the
documentary intended for me to kind of
digest yes I agree but
it was an interesting window into a
fascinating girl and I just hope I
stated that you know 2020 Selena is not
in the same place as 2022 Selena and I
feel like given we know the external
changes that have happened in her life I
feel like she isn't in that place
anymore I don't think so either and I
just wish like there were more tools for
people who are still in that place to
have like to be inspired yeah no totally
it wasn't inspirational
yeah no
so those are my
we'll also talk about the Culpo show
which premiered last night we have a
story and I feel like I'm I'm ready okay
without further Ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
today's episode is sponsored by Bare
Necessities think about the favorite bra
you have right now what's so great about
it chances are it's not anything the bra
actually does it's more the things it
doesn't do it has weird gaps shows
through your shirt digs through it into
your shoulders same thing with underwear
you reach for the ones that don't ride
up or don't give you a panty line your
bra and underwear should make your
outfit better not worse and that's
what's so great about Bare Necessities
the biggest online Intimate Apparel
retailer offering over 140 of the Best
Brands all in one place they put fit and
comfort above all else so they're all
about size and inclusivity their band
sizes go from 28 to 58 their cup sizes
go from double A to O and the regular
sizes go from excess extra small to 5xl
5 extra large
with so many options finding the right
bra isn't always intuitive so they offer
the bra finder fit quiz that point to in
the right direction in just a few clicks
Bare Necessities also has a team of bra
fit experts available on hand to help
you find your perfect bra so I've been
wearing like the same brand of bra and
undies forever and it's it's so true
like they're not great it's just like
what you have yeah
um so when you take the time to like
find exactly what you need when it comes
to bra and underwear whether it comes
like band size cup size underwear like I
happen to like underwear that's like you
know goes up a little higher I feel like
it holds me together more but I also
find that the ones that I used to wear
leave like crazy lines on my pants and
my leggings so taking the time to
actually find what you need out of
LeBron undies is such an important thing
and I feel like that's the whole concept
behind Bare Necessities like it's so
important like let's actually take the
time figure out what your needs are and
Bare Necessities has a product for you I
also love that their sizing is has such
a wide range because like we all have
such different bodies and even two
people with similar bodies are going to
need two totally different bra sizes
right now you can also get 20 off your
bare necessities order when you go to
barnecessities.com use code toast20
that's code toast20 at barenessities.com
to get 20 off bearnecessities.com code
toast20 some exclusions apply today's
episode is also brought to you by
Jackie's favorite Babble if you're like
us there's a foreign language that you
regret not learning in school and it's
never too late to start with Babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions thanks to
Babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons you can
finally cross learning that new language
off your list so they offer 14 different
languages including Spanish French
Italian and German whatever the reason
is that you might want to start learning
a new language one because it's just a
fun way to broaden your horizons expand
your mind as an adult two you know you
don't remember everything from high
school French like Meghan Markle or you
know are you taking a trip where you
just want to learn like the basic
language so that you know you don't get
lost or it can be kind of
scary to be in a new country where you
don't know the language I did that
before I went to Italy with Babel you
need only 10 minutes to complete a
lesson so you can start having real life
conversations in a new language in as
little as three weeks other language
learning apps use AI for their lesson
plans but Babel lessons were created by
over 150 language experts and voiced by
real native speakers not computers their
teaching method has been scientifically
proven to be effective again you can
choose from Spanish French Italian
German they have over 14 languages and
right now you can get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
TMT that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com TMT for up to 55 off
your subscription Babble it's language
for life again that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash TMT as in the
morning toast TMT for 55 off your
subscription it's addictively fun and
there's never a bad time to learn a new
language like it's just like something
that's good for you in your adult life
um
are you ready for our first story it's
so sexy I just it's a little too NSFW
it's getting hot in here it's getting
hot in here because people has announced
their 2022 sexiest man alive and it is
Chris Evans he says quote my mom will be
so happy
that's funny if you were to tell a
middle age Middle School age middle-aged
Middle School age Chris Evans that he
would one day be named people sexiest
man alive he'd be pumped he said this
would probably be the road to the cool
table which I was not at how convenient
every celebrity was a loser growing up
okay wait I can we talk about that for a
second yeah
so that's so true like every celebrity
was like I was never cool I had no
friends like he's the most gorgeous like
personal perfect looking like you know
funny but but it's like obviously hard
to believe when you see them now in like
their peer Perfection
um
I used to roll my eyes at them but I
feel like for actors musicians like most
of them were like theater kids they were
in choir they were in band they were in
like traditionally like back in our day
like traditionally uncool
extracurriculars and I actually think
like the possibility that a lot of most
celebrities were losers like in high
school and middle school like it's
probably true yeah because they were
working on their art
no and like now and I'm so jealous of
the kids who like are growing up now
like things to honestly like shows like
Glee and stuff like those like being in
band and wanting to join the drama
Department like it's there's not as much
of a stigma as it used to be but like
back in my day like it was the worst
thing you could do socially like oh my
God banned I'd rather die yeah so I
believe it I mean I believe it when
people say it of course but it does make
sense from for actors who are in theater
and musicians who are focusing on their
instruments and their art art
um but let's talk about the models who
are always like I was like so bullying
nobody I was so tall and gorgeous okay
well let's also talk about that nobody
wants to be my friend I do think there's
a certain sect of modeling where it's
like not traditionally beautiful women
it's more like interesting looking women
who were like very tall and I could see
those girls you know being losers and
getting like bullied I could see that
yes uh no these perfect All-American
girlies like I'm not buying it yeah
I'm not buying it yeah
anyways Young Chris Evans would be happy
to know that old Chris Evans is sexy as
hell he said my mom will be so happy
she's proud of everything I do but this
is something she can really brag about
he sat down for his interview and said
this whole thing is tough to be
interviewed about it feels like a weird
form of humble bragging really this will
just be a point of bullying from his
close friends it's ripe for harassment
that's funny
um obviously Chris Evans is extremely
good looking like it's not even a
question
I do want to say I'm like a little
uninspired by this Choice it's like so
obvious you know that's like choosing me
for most sexy woman you know it's like
it's a duh you know I like when they get
a little creative and do someone who's
like a little ugly but like still really
hot you know what I mean like and if
like there's no controversy around this
like everyone's like yeah okay great but
like remember when Blake Shelton was and
everyone was like the country was torn
apart
I kind of lived for that like be a
little out there
who would you have liked to see
well it also has to be someone it's not
just about looks it also has to be
someone who's been like really relevant
this year was a movie coming out who
wants to sit down for this interview not
just like some recluse who would write
so it's like a party to choose
oh honestly it really should be just
based on the year Harry Styles yeah
oh sorry it should be Miles Teller but I
do feel like they choose someone older
usually like Harry and miles are a
little young that's true and I think
that's nice
yeah I mean do they do that for the
women yeah it's like always like a woman
it's always Julia Roberts no one has
Tina it's always and it's not sexiest
woman it's most beautiful I think which
is the hell up I don't think they do it
anymore it's so problematic also like I
do see a time I feel like I say this
every year I'm like surprised that they
still do it because it's so binary you
know yeah really sexiest man I know but
it's like they canceled the most
beautiful woman but not
sexiest man like what about us I don't
know like I feel like Maxim really has
like the list for women you know maybe
people was just like becoming irrelevant
like that list people look forward to
the maximum Hot 100 and they really look
forward to the sexiest man alive I don't
think anybody really cared about most
beautiful woman
it's true and also this is so
interesting so they have their sexiest
man alive then they one year did a
sexiest woman alive in 2014 and it was
Kate Upton
and then they have most beautiful people
not most beautiful woman oh okay so in
last year it was Helen Mirren
she is stunning she is stunning she's
stunning I absolutely I'm never mind
laughing she's stunning and I love her
it's just like a
like uh just like a crazy choice you
know yeah and I just want you to know
for the record Julia Roberts has won
five times so I'm not even exactly so it
is always her yeah it's always her
I mean that smile it really is beautiful
it is but I think the women I mean the
women have plenty of lists but then like
people get mad about female lists but
right like we're putting women a list I
love a list
I love a list too especially one that
I'm on
uh you would be my number one every day
yeah you would I would be my number one
too
every year but to me again not trying to
be controversial the sexiest man alive
is Bryce but people don't see it
no I I definitely see strikes it should
be the sexiest man alive brass and
stress love love love we'll have to know
most beautiful woman of the year we'll
have to photoshop that cover ourselves
on our person make the SMA cover you
wish to see in the world
um I just feel like
and I feel like I have the same thoughts
every year but like the fact that Chris
Evans who's arguably like the biggest
movie star in the world is sitting down
with People magazine is like so crazy
because People magazine is like a trash
tabloid and this one thing that they do
is like a redeeming thing and it's like
they get like George Clooney like who
would never talk to People magazine
yeah you know I was thinking about
George Clooney recently about his like
catalog of movies because I feel like
he's so serious you know when you think
of like the most serious actors most
respected but I feel like his movies are
actually kind like floppio like
flopville yeah and like stupid wait
let's talk for real about what movies
that obviously the ocean the oceans
movies which aren't like oscar-winning
movies but they're they're good
blockbuster movies and he's in this new
one with Julia Roberts that looks so
stupid but it's so stupid it's doing
amazing at the box office but I'm like
George Clooney does stupid movies
up in the air with Anna Kendrick all
about the miles I never saw that one but
that was based on a book so it had to be
good right
I never saw it and he was on ER so he's
like a soap actor
good call like have we been gaslit into
thinking that George Clooney is a
serious actor yeah like has he ever even
been nominated for an Oscar Google if
he's been nominated for an oscar but I
think it's because I really Loop him in
with like Brad Pitt and Brad Pitt has
been nominated one many Oscars he
produces like Brad Pitt is the
definition of a serious actor Benjamin
Button
um
Moneyball I mean there's a million like
yeah oh wait hold on listen has George
Clooney ever been nominated for an Oscar
yes yes oh he he won best supporting
actor in 2006. for for syriana
he was nominated six other times and
then he also won with Best Picture in
Argo
Argo but he was a producer oh
oh
well sound off in the comments is George
Clooney a serious actor he also received
have we been gaslit into thinking as so
is he just LARPing as a serious actor
really seriously by the way but he also
received the Golden Globe Cecil B
Demille award in 2015 which is a very
serious award for serious actors
maybe there's like an era of his
career that like I'm either not thinking
of or not familiar with but I'm now
fully convinced George Clooney has been
LARPing I just I thought it was an
interesting thought I had and I wanted
to share it it's it's a thought that is
definitely interesting sound off in the
comments great are you ready for our
next story yes a little hot new couple
alert Jackson white confirms he's dating
his tell me lies co-star Grace Van
Patten so the two of them showed up to
the cfda awards last night together they
held hands for a picture and then he
also shared on social media a picture of
their photo booth strip and he blocked
out the third picture with an emoji and
they're clearly kissing in that picture
yeah I feel like there's been
speculation for a while
um in my mind it was confirmed so this
is great they looked fabulous on that
red carpet together like they're both
really I don't know how long it'll last
but the show is really popular and
they're both like kind of like it
girlies and boys right now yeah it's
really they're also both nepo babies
it's unfortunate it for me because the
hatred that I have for their characters
and their relationship is seeping over
into this relationship and like I am not
as excited about it as I would be
if this was a beloved television
relationship
no like do you think that their
relationship is really toxic no no I'm
sure I'm sure they're nothing like their
characters but like that's how
strongly I feel about the show you were
really really impacted by the show I
really was I had really strong feelings
about it I usually don't with fiction I
can separate I can separate the two like
in real life I'm like obsessed with
these two I think they're so good
looking they're both like very into
fashion they were very well dressed at
the cfda awards they've had like these
iconic photo shoots since the show came
out like I can separate but I totally
respect that you can't there are certain
things I can't separate yeah honestly
the perfect example is like okay
remember bring it on the one with Hayden
Panettiere and Solange Knowles of course
and remember the actress who
um was Hayden Panettiere's friend at her
other school and then became Captain
Winnie when Winnie when Hayden left that
actress was so evil I never saw her
again and anything else but I hate her
to my core yeah but you didn't even see
her again in something else like maybe
you have to see her outside of that
character to see no
because I I remember thinking like I
remember being so deeply moved by my
hatred for her she was also like [ __ ]
racist like uh she was evil she was evil
and that's a hatred that I've carried
with me throughout all the years like
she's too good of an actress maybe
that's why she never got another big
part because she was so Typecast
because she was too good she was too
good
so I understand that is what I'm saying
yeah but anyways like I'm happy for
everyone who's obviously like living for
this I just like for some reason can
separate the art
on this from the artist on this one no
that's yeah it's a testament
to their craft in a way you're
complimenting them if you think about it
like that and I'm complimenting the show
because
I can't remember the last time I cared
so deeply about a fictional show no it's
so true
so make fictional shows great again
that's what they're doing at tell me
lies literally literally are you ready
for our next story
I I really truly am Alanis Morissette
bailed on the Carly Simon Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame it's a mouthful
she bailed on the Rock Carly Simon rock
and roll rock and roll I'm sorry Roland
Hall next to each other Roll Hall okay
wait
Carly Simon wait what is it Alanis
Morissette bailed on Carly Simon Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame tribute
Alanis Morissette bailed on Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame performance
you okay whatever I couldn't remember
the rest of what you said Alanis asked
her performance at the 37th annual Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame induction ceremony
I wonder if other people struggle with
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame I don't think
so Rock and Roll Hall of Fame Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame it's when you look at
it the singer was set to perform Carly
Simon's You're So Vain along with Olivia
Rodrigo but she bowed out at the last
minute after rehearsal on Friday an
Insider told page six The Insider said
when she ran through it the first time
with Olivia it seemed like they weren't
prepared Carly's guitarist Jimmy Ryan
leaked that Alanis was performing last
month in a since deleted Facebook post
but the Hall of Fame never officially
confirmed her as one of the reporters at
performers geez oh my God are you okay
this story is just full of twists and
turns after Friday's rehearsal
organizers received notification that
Alanis has chosen not to perform she
addressed the last minute cancellation
on her story she said in part I've spent
decades in an industry that is Rife with
an overarching anti-woman sentiment and
have tolerated a lot of condescension
and disrespectfulness reduction
dismissiveness contract breaching
unsupportiveness exploitation and
psychological violence and more
throughout my career I tolerated it
because nothing would stop me from
connecting with those whom I care about
and resonated with I live to serve and
connect with people and so over the
years I sucked it up on more occasions
than I can count in order to do so it's
hard not to be affected in any industry
around the world but Hollywood has been
notorious for its disrespect of the
feminine in all of us she says now I'm
at a point in my life where there's no
need for me to spend time in an
environment that reduces women such as
this Hall of Fame performance uh she
said a lot of words it's a lot of words
to tell us nothing about what happened
she's got nothing but love for Carly
Olivia Dolly Parton Janet Jackson Pat
Benatar Sheryl Crow pink and Brandi
Carlisle and Sara Bareilles all of whom
are doing the tribute but the
environment was just I guess right Rife
with too much anti-woman sentiment
okay I totally agree that like I'm sure
her career has been filled with tarch
and like people disrespect but like if
you're gonna make a whole statement like
we need to know what happened
yeah and there's so many other women who
are performing like are they just
like they're putting up with the
anti-women sentiment
Dolly Parton wouldn't put up with that
right so I'm not saying I I don't I
don't know at all what the [ __ ] happened
I have no skin in the rock and roll
serum uh but like if we're gonna call
them out let's call them out all the way
what the [ __ ] happened oh okay so that
actually reminded me are you following
this Glennon Doyle podcast thing no
what's the T it's a crazy story okay you
know Glennon Doyle who by the way is
married to Abby Wambach like iconic
soccer player it's just like an iconic
Duo they have a podcast and it's like
super popular I'm sure and Glennon Doyle
wrote the book Untamed which is like one
of the biggest books of the last ever 20
years yeah okay so they have a podcast
together and they released an episode
called like the podcast or the episode
that never was and basically they went
on to say they just recorded like uh an
interview with us a guest and the guest
was so rude to like the producer and
like the people that work for Glennon
and Abby and you know Glennon and Abby
are going to will stand by their team
they're not releasing the episode and
this person is banned from the podcast
it was this person and their husband
so now everyone's up in arms being like
who the [ __ ] was it and like Glennon you
know she's a businesswoman she's being
all clickbaity not saying who it is but
like trying to drop Clues and like like
so for a while everybody
um had reason to believe it was Chip and
Joe
um but then Glennon I believe on her
Instagram dispelled that now people are
saying it's Mel Robbins I have no idea
who that is also people are saying it
could be Kelly Ripa and Mark Consuelos
because her husband I believe was the
husband was the one being rude
huh why do they think it's them I'm
looking at who Mel Robbins is I don't
know I didn't listen so then they
released a whole episode just about like
you know
kindness
um and I guess there were some things in
there that like dropped Clues and so
people are using just like social media
people who are currently promoting
things people who promote things with
their husbands people are just um
like using context clues for guessing
there's really no
definitive answer as to who it is but
like I'm so curious and if anyone has a
guess or like anybody knows like just DM
me I won't tell anyone I'm just curious
hmm
not that interesting yeah sort of
but then it's like the same thing it's
like you're gonna tease it well just
tell us well I mean you did the same
thing on Friday
about the Amazon event
oh I did but that's because
um
why did I do that I I mean if it were up
to me and I experienced it I wouldn't
have even mentioned it you know no
because I feel like
and this is what I believe Glennon was
saying like you deserve to be called out
if you're every person but are you even
calling someone out if you're not
actually calling them out
and instead you're making you're kind of
like speculating and it's seeping into
other people who most of them have
that's nothing to do with this that's
true like then people start saying like
it's Remy Bader and like it's not yeah
people say it's Chipotle and like for
some people who never actually get the
real answer it's like in their heads
no that's a really good point so what do
I do about that now
um no nothing to be done okay
but thank you for calling me out of my
hypocrisy like you're so right no but I
didn't mean to like call you out I'm
just like what what are the Scruples
like what are this stupid I just I
believe the sentiments say about this
but there are just people who walk
around this planet like celebrities
influencers who are just [ __ ] rude
and like it's like a it's like an
Insider secret but it's like you know
you want to be rude own it I'm gonna
tell everyone you're [ __ ] rude yeah
but I didn't you're right
and you just like we never know what
someone on the like what their story
they are coming from like you just never
know but is that an excuse for bad
behavior no but like maybe if you had
the whole picture like it it might not
have been bad behavior
do you know what I mean like maybe
that's someone defending themselves what
like maybe someone who is experiencing
Injustice
yeah I mean it's very nuanced that's
clearly the takeaway here but like for
me I'm like a gossip Monger like I want
people to say the names but you're right
I just did that yeah
so so I think
I don't know it's it's complicated
it's complicated for sure and that's how
I feel about call out culture in general
I know so
I feel torn between like you really
don't know like what someone's day has
been thus far and like maybe if they're
like a little testy to you one time like
and how were you acting were you acting
like a beast going up to someone at a
restaurant with their family being like
can I get a selfie and they say no like
honestly like I think perception is a
huge part of it I think like you don't
know what people are going through in
that moment I think that's a huge part
of it too but also sometimes someone's
just an ass of course and and I think
that we should talk about it of course
but I think there's so many upsetters
there are so many different things that
like go into someone's recollection of a
specific change and it's like they could
quote verbatim like you could be telling
the story and say exactly what that
person said to you but depending on the
tone in which you say it it means two
completely different things and total is
not something that can be adequately
recollected it's subjective that's
it's so well said tone is more personal
than comedy more personal than food
so true and then there's the issue of
people's memories
yeah well you know that's like a thing
in law like eyewitnesses are more often
than not like totally [ __ ] wrong it
sounds like a thing in books they're
always talking about about how like
memories are just like I don't feel like
this is true because I feel like I have
a good memory no my memories are perfect
yeah especially when it just happened
like okay sure maybe from when I was six
I have I'm you know right remembering it
fondly but like
what I like I'm not making [ __ ] off like
no like I'm 100 right always I know what
I saw
right I said what I said
tactic to tell us that like our memories
are just false
you're so right the government they're
making us feel crazy 100
even though like I feel like I learned
that thing about eyewitnesses from my
cousin Vinnie
yeah that like there was that eyewitness
and she was [ __ ] wrong and also 12
Angry Men
I never saw it it's a book too I never
read it
I think I read it it was a good message
but here's the thing imagine you're at
Zia
you prancing along you get a little
thirsty you spot a little Brook
you put your little dear lips down to
the cool clear water and Bam a [ __ ]
bullet rips off part of your head your
brains are laying on the ground in
little bloody pieces
would you give a [ __ ] what kind of pants
instead of a [ __ ] who shot you was
wearing
it's a great question it's a great
question
are you ready for our next story
is it the story
that's brought to you by ZipRecruiter
per chance yes it is
are you hiring
what type of role are you hiring for
here at the toast we are always looking
for different people to boost our
business to work with us as a team maybe
you need someone who wears many hats and
that could be challenging to hire for or
you have a simple position to fill but
it is taking forever to find someone
who's a great fit for your company
whether you need to hire a civil
engineer in New York a pediatric nurse
in Nebraska an attorney in Colorado even
a mascot in Missouri ZipRecruiter can
help you find qualified candidates fast
and you can try zip recruiter for free
right now when you go to
ziprecruiter.com toast from accountants
to zoologists and everything in between
zip recruiters matching technology finds
people with the right experience for
your job and presents them to you then
you can invite your top choices to apply
it's so effective that four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
we have used zip recruiter in the past
um to hire for different roles and it
has been so seamless it's really the
best way to find quality candidates
and again you can try it now for free at
our exclusive link which is
ziprecruiter.com toast once again that
is ZipRecruiter zip Rec
r-u-i-t-e-r.com slash toast
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire check it out whether you're a
small business a big business you're
looking for any certain type of roll zip
recruiter is really the company to do
that for you and you won't regret it
ziprecruiter.com toast
great our next story a little shadiness
at the Powerball the Powerball drawing
for 1.9 billion dollars jackpot has been
delayed due to security protocol issues
the highly anticipated drawing for the
record 1.9 billion Powerball
jackpot was delayed Monday night leaving
people eagerly anticipating those
winning numbers Powerball officials
released a statement early Tuesday
morning saying one participating Lottery
is still processing its sales and play
data and all that 48 and that all 48
participating lotteries are required to
submit their Data before the winning
numbers can be drawn the statement said
that Powerball has stringent security
requirements to protect the Integrity of
the game and remains committed to
holding a drawing that gives all players
a fair chance to win so due to the delay
the results will likely not be known
until this morning and they were
released and any winners
um I believe so I believe a winning
ticket was drawn
I saw it this morning hang on let me
just for the full 1.9
actually I don't know let me just do a
fresh so as NPR as of 47 minutes ago
it's not clear yet if anyone won
Monday's delayed two billion dollar
Powerball drawing
okay that's not clear yet I mean I hope
that there's if if there's someone out
there they claim their prize I think
that this is a little shady it's giving
it's giving a great Millions
hey shady I don't like it I don't like
it one bit and if I bought a ticket I
would demand
well if I bought a ticket and lost I
would demand to redo
did you watch mcmillions
yes it's just reminding me of that like
have to start looking into these
Powerball winners could be someone with
their thumb on the ball
oh 100
somebody it's somebody's cousin
somebody's it's the person whose thumb
is on the ball it's their cousin you
know but then their cousin's neighbor
like cash is the price and then they
ruin that neighbor's life because the
neighbor wins obviously but they have to
give the money to the neighbor their
neighbor's cousin and they barely get to
keep some for themselves they think
their life has changed but it hasn't and
then the feds come after them and that's
what happened with mcmillions and it was
so [ __ ] sad
it was a sad documentary
um in this case I'm just you know I'm a
little I'm a little suspicious you know
I feel like I've been alive for almost
30 years I've lived through many
lotteries and I've never heard of it
being delayed it's a little shady is all
I'm saying but that's the thing it's
like a security issue nobody respects
cyber security anymore it's every day
I'm getting an email oh our data your
password changed it like excuse me yeah
nobody's taking cyber security seriously
and they shouldn't
it's leaked and it's hacked and it's
this and it's that and all I know is I
gotta change my password for like really
important [ __ ] mm-hmm
and I don't like it not one bit
but you are like I mean and me too it's
like if you don't like these companies
cyber security protocols like don't
engage with the company you can't well
then don't don't create a society in
which I'm forced to engage with the
company no I like I have to live I'm
struggling with this too
I'm struggling
yeah okay like I could you know not use
a Facebook but it's like it's connected
to my Instagram and how do I remember
people's birthdays and people use it for
work it's like yeah we live in a society
where I don't have to be on Facebook
legally
but literally I do yeah
so and that's just a little bit about me
yeah and the Powerball is
questionable now and I feel like and I
just feel Integrity nobody yeah nobody
respects the Powerball you know and now
I'm gonna be looking at this winner a
little sideways which is might be
completely unfair
so true no if there's a winner this time
like I've I'm keeping an eye out for the
winner for the Selena
yeah no I'm suspicious for sure
do you think if you work for for Mega
Millions or like any of these companies
like you're legally not allowed to buy
tickets kind of how like if you're a
J like a blackjack dealer you can't play
Blackjack in the state that you're
licensed in you know
it's an interesting question
I feel like if you work for like
Powerball corporate like you run the
Powerball Instagram or something like
you can't buy tickets I don't know why I
just feel like you wouldn't be allowed I
just feel like because no one would take
your win seriously and they'd come after
you right we'd be like sure jazz is it
worth it
right right
and you would do it too for a check
our fifth and final story which is going
to lead into a little TV recap Olivia
Culpo reflects on her breakup with Nick
Jonas she said quote I thought we were
going to get married so let me tell you
how I forgot these two even dated when I
saw these headlines like Olivia Culpo is
reflecting on her breakup I thought she
was talking about Danny Amendola that's
a different breakup last night the new
show the Culpo sisters which is reality
show about Olivia Culpo and her coppo
sisters premiered on TLC we've talked
about it a little bit and there was some
really good tea and I have so many
thoughts about the show in general but
we'll start with this one tidbit because
Olivia was doing one of her interviews
and she's talking about like why she
moved to LA in the first place and she
was like well I moved with my boyfriend
and the interviewers like didn't you
date a Jonas brother like was it Nick
and she was like do we really have to
talk about this and then she was like
yes I dated Nick Jonas and interesting
tea was that he broke up with her she
like was really so in love with him and
when she came to LA with him she just
one Miss Universe she didn't have a job
and she moved into her apartment after
they broke up she like really couldn't
afford her rent she had like no she said
she had like no sense of self no job
like didn't know where she was going to
go from here like she really thought
like her and Nick were gonna get married
as she said and it was a big change for
her she said I moved to LA with him I
had no brand no money and I was in love
that was great right but when he broke
up with me I was kind of left with no
sense of identity my whole identity was
in him which is a very common story of a
young person in love I thought we were
going to get married I thought all the
things and I just remember night after
night looking up at my ceiling in my
apartment that I couldn't afford
thinking to myself how am I going to pay
my rent
no by the way like it that is exactly
how I remember it like her identity was
very partially related to like her
pageantry but it was really like
Nick Jonas's girlfriend and I didn't
really think about how like after they
broke up like where was she living like
you know yeah and I remember I feel like
I can sort of remember like the early
days of her being in LA and and then
breaking up and then she started posting
on Instagram I've been following her on
Instagram like since I think I had an
Instagram and she really like built this
brand
and what she does now I think a lot of
people do being influencers brand
ambassadors models Etc multi-hypnit but
at the time was not a job so it's not
like she woke up but I think I'll be an
influencer today she just like really
put all the pieces together and like was
influential yeah and knew what her
strengths were and now she has a
wonderful career and this wonderful
television show which I guess I didn't
recap I I didn't watch it I feel like
they're a great family for television
I'm just like so confused why it's on
TLC which is like the circus Channel
like it's like you know like crazy
stories the man with the 19 pound
scrotum 19 Kids and Counting yeah even
the commercial thousand pound sisters
this was not thousand pound sisters no
it's not
Network they're definitely a little out
of place I think one like that's who won
in their show maybe TLC is trying to
elevate their brand and so maybe they
made them the best offer and the show
was also streaming on Discovery plus
which is a premium streamer like you're
there yes
Magnolia Network and so that's that's
where the show went and luckily it's on
YouTube TV so I was able to add it to my
library and enjoy and I just want to say
overall the first episode you know there
were highs and lows but generally
speaking it was a breath of fresh air
and I want to explain why obviously I'm
an Olivia coppo apologist and
um but following her on Instagram and
watching her for an hour on television
is a different experience and I'm not
sure that I always want to watch a
reality show about someone that I follow
on Instagram so it's not a
chewing at all but what I loved about
the show was that like there was just
this like General and maybe it was like
coming off of having watched that
documentary where I felt really sad and
I was like I want to watch like more
happy people and people who are enjoying
life even though obviously everyone has
their struggles like watching this show
like they're so close as sisters they're
like real sisters because they love each
other but they also have their like beef
you know the little one is very snitchy
like oh my God I wanted to I wanted
Margo to watch it because some of the
stuff Sophia was saying I feel like
Margot says to her friends about us like
how we should totally she's trying to
grow and we just always remember her as
the baby and we like won't let her grow
so I thought that was really cute and it
was just like they really are
a great family who love each other
they're so close with their parents
they're so close with each other they
have two other brothers who they're also
really close with when Sophia lives with
Olivia like her parents came to town for
their 35th wedding anniversary and
Olivia's like we're throwing them a
party we're throwing them a party and
the whole time I thought it was going to
be like a big party but it was just all
of them having dinner in her backyard
which is just so sweet like they really
love each other so much and they have
such a great relationship and you can
see how like Olivia having her sisters
there and having such a great
relationship with them like
she's so grounded in her career you know
she is like this huge star and her
boyfriend is Christian McCaffrey and
like you could think that she would be
like one of these like La girls who you
know thinks that they're obsessed with
the face obsessed with the fame like so
affected but no she's just like balloon
shopping with her sisters for her
parents anniversary and like talking
about how she really wants to be a mom
and she's turning 30 and like she that
you know when she was younger would have
thought that she would have a husband
and three kids by now and that hasn't
happened for her but like she's so
determined to do it like they really put
such an emphasis on family I feel like
family not something that we see a lot
of anymore and I think it's also a
reason why the Kardashians are so
successful yeah a lot of people have
tried to do that and put their families
on TV but it doesn't work for a number
of reasons you might be an uninteresting
family you might not have a good family
Dynamic you guys might all be throwing
on each other under the bus for a lick
of Fame and I didn't get any of those
vibes from the Copo sisters show I
thought it was just really positive and
refreshing there was some stupid like
sublines very Kardashians you know
they're trying to like wellness things
but there was also some tea like Aurora
the oldest sister
um she's been married for three years
and I think right now she is going
through a divorce and on the show I
think it all unfolds on the show she
starts talking about how she with her
sisters and she's like someone DM me on
Instagram and said that do you know your
husband's cheating on you
and she was like what do you mean and
she spoke to her husband about it but
then she also revealed that when they
did get married three years ago she told
her husband that he could have like one
extramarital thing a year
so I don't know if he like went over his
limit or maybe that actually just
doesn't work for her but she's like
struggling in her marriage and being
really open about it and then in the
preview for the rest of the season like
it really feels like they're sharing a
lot like I think Olivia is starting to
feel like she wants more commitment from
Christian and she wants to have kids and
she has endometriosis and I think that
will yeah she said it makes it so that
she has a different sort of window for
when she's gonna when she can have kids
she said if I miss my window like I
don't know if I would ever forgive
myself so I feel like things might come
up with her and Christian and then there
are some sister fights that look like so
[ __ ] real
um between like her and Sophia they
definitely get under each other's skin
but they also live together like hello
yeah right you know it's fights about
clothes which is the biggest problem
relatable most sisters have I think also
Sophia's career is very similar to
Olivia's so I think there's tension
there in the way like I think Olivia see
Sophia doing things and she's like
that's not how I would do them I think
Sophia probably also feels like she's in
her Shadow and she wants some show
herself it felt like there's a lot of
realness coupled with uh reality shows
reality TV dumbness and I have to be
honest I I kind of expected that it
wouldn't be as great as I thought as I
would hope because I love her so much
but I thought it was such a pleasure to
watch and fabulous it was really
refreshing to see
grounded level-headed happy people who
love their family and who are enjoying
their life like Olivia has this gorgeous
house in L.A and like every room is
filled with people dogs food love like
it's it's a pleasure yeah
it's a pleasure so I would recommend it
because okay good not everything needs
to be so sad
so heavy yeah and they have their
struggles and everybody does and I'm not
saying I don't want to see it or we
shouldn't like not at all but there
needs to be balance a balance yeah yeah
no that sounds nice so I felt a balanced
at the end of the day
one thing about you is like you have
balance you know I strive for balance I
do it's so important in all facets
um so that's our show thank you that was
a gorgeous TV recap really in depth and
stunning thanks am I are you feeling
like you want to check it out oh and
could they be more I'm just like not
taking anything new on could they be
more beautiful the whole family the
girls no they're really stuck Brothers
the parents we gotta set the brother up
with snitch do you think it'll convert
no I think they're
um religious yeah she literally was also
talking about how like her her religion
is a big part of her relationship with
Christian and when they go through hard
times like they pray together to get
through it
that's the cutest thing
um in Love is Blind like this one couple
like preyed on each other and like it
was actually really sweet even though
like that's like not something I do I
like respected it yeah no I I respect it
like just seeing the different ways that
people go through hard times like
they're even I pray for you
I thank you mclart I pray for it I pray
for you
that is our show that is the greatest
show on Earth
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the Monday Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so at
Spotify iTunes Stitch or public video I
got rid of guestbox all the places so if
you listen to podcasts find us the toast
and leave a five-star review about how
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have
an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day bye